what up friends drex's coming at you
with a review of the new ignis pixel 48
NG these are new programmable poy that
come out of ignis pixel and I've been
playing with them now for a few months
and I'd love to share with you my
thoughts Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today I am going to be talking
a little bit about one of those POI
products that you might want to pick up
for yourself but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca beckon thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission all right so ignis
pixel they have been around quite a
while now and they are one of the big
players in the game of programmable POI
programmable POI are specifically those
kinds of poi that have a series of LED
strips inside of them that when they
turn off and on if you wave them back
and forth really rapidly you'll see a
picture in them uh and specifically they
have the capacity to program what that
picture might be via either your phone
or a program that you can put on your
laptop the NG is the new generation of
this product I wonder if that's what it
stands for and these are the 48 pixel
version I've had these now for almost 3
months and uh in that time I've gotten
to know them pretty well so I'd love to
tell you a few of the things that I have
picked up on them in the process I'm
going to more or less follow my usual
review rubric here so we're going to
talk a little bit about features ease of
use battery life brightness uh
durability and of course I'm going to
share with you my personal
thoughts so if you don't know the basics
of programmable poy basically you have
these long rod-shaped housings that have
strips of LED in them and you have a
series of buttons on the casing that
helps you turn them on as well as
navigate your way through the different
modes um these particular po are the
first programable poy that I have seen
with
USBC uh ports in them both for charging
as well as connecting to your laptop and
programming them which is awesome uh way
to be on top of that game ignis um and
also too they are each about 13.9 in
long with the display area itself making
up a whole 13 in of that 13.9 in which
is really cool actually cuz um actually
I can show you here because I have one
of their older POI um usually when you
see programmable poy what happens is the
buttons and all of the batteries and all
that take up like you know 20% of the
length of the entire poy which leaves
the other 80% to be the LEDs in this
case we actually have a product where
pretty much the entire length of the
housing is taken up by the LED which is
really cool to see they have somewhere
in the neighborhood of 60 slots for
individual images to save on the PO
themselves as well as if memory serves
like four slots for putting in a
specific program that you could like
write to a piece of music or something
like that um should also be said they
have these uh kind of looks like nylon
cords that come out as tethers and then
they have these uh double Loop handles
here to go around your fingers to Anchor
the poy and of course the other cool
thing about these POI is that you can
control them with the ignis smartphone
app not only does the app allow you to
control the brightness of the POI but it
can also allow you to change what image
the poy are displaying and activate
different programs on them uh plus which
one of my personal favorite things about
it it also includes a a fitness tracker
so it'll keep track of how long you've
been spinning and give you a rough
estimate of how many calories you burned
in the process um I've always thought
that was a cool feature and yeah it
works with these two included with the
poy when you get them is a small
carrying bag as well as a couple of USBC
uh cables to plug these in and uh you
also get these very interesting 3D
printed kind of like platforms it took
me a while to figure out what they were
for but turns out you can unscrew the
cap that connects the tether to the
handle and there's a little recess in
here and you can actually screw it in to
those base plates and just like set them
down as though you were using them for
mood lighting or something I don't know
I've been using them when
charging so when it comes to ease of use
one of those things that I think ignis
does really well is their poy come with
a bunch of pre-installed images on them
so if you want to right from the get-go
you can just turn them on and hit play
and you'll automatically get an image
that you can spin around with it's
pretty nifty um I will also say that
their smartphone app remains in my
opinion the gold standard for an app to
control po uh it's really intuitive how
you activate the different images and
colors and timelines and all that um
absolutely every feature that I could
want is really easily accessible on the
app so uh I I know that the app was
developed before these po but it's a big
part of how I interact with these Po and
I still appreciate it and of course
these POI have this little three button
interface where the middle button right
here is turning the PO on and off as
well as pausing or playing a particular
uh a a program that you put into it you
can use these other buttons to the side
to navigate through the different
programs or images that it has on it um
this is pretty intuitive I figured this
out relatively quickly uh when I I first
started using his ignis products years
ago
so without Pier the biggest Achilles
heel of any set of programmable POI made
by any manufacturer with any kind of
form factor or however many pixels they
have is going to be the battery life and
these are no different when I do the
most punishing test I light up the POI
white as bright as they will go uh and
in the case of these POI it takes about
20 minutes for them to lose all their
battery life to drain their batteries
which you know as as programmable poy go
is like kind of standard they don't
usually last that long with uh with the
lights set that way um the less
punishing test is I actually set the PO
to a rainbow fade and that gave me a
whole 4 hours of battery life so more
than likely your performance is going to
be somewhere hovering around the 4our
mark but just know that the more demands
you put on the battery the shorter that
battery life get
gets all right so let's talk durability
which is very frequently the other
Achilles heel of programmable POI um
namely because we have these Long Rod
form factors if they like have a
collision with something kind of bends
the circuit board and that will mean
that sometimes it'll knock out specific
pixels I've been playing with these
pretty regularly now for about 3 months
and I've yet to see any of that happen
with them they still make that awful
noise that happens when any two
programmable po
Collide do not like but so far as I can
tell they've been holding up pretty well
I have one and only one complaint in
this department and that is that uh the
buttons on one of the PO the onoff
button kind of got stuck inside of this
little recess right here um so now I can
only get the button to work when I push
like the very edge of it but if I just
push the center of the button like one
would expect it does nothing at all um
the PO still works don't get me wrong
it's just kind of annoying but also too
it's kind of annoying so I would be a
little careful with these buttons If I
were you um and I'm not sure if there's
a fix for that out there but I just
thought I would mention
it okay so the real question how do
these feel do I enjoy spinning with them
uh and the answer to the latter question
is yes so I actually quite like the way
that these feel uh usually I kind of
dread doing reviews of programmable POI
because the form factor just doesn't
really jive with the way that I spin um
that's changed a lot in recent years and
I'm starting to enjoy spinning with this
form factor a lot more now these have a
really good feel the weight is really
good I love the Cosmetics of these um
the whole idea of having the control
panel integrated right next to the LEDs
and making it just one complete unit I
think is fantastic these look gorgeous I
love the look of them as soon as I
pulled them out of the bag um yeah just
cosmetically I have no complaints here
these are beautiful I will say that as I
was testing these out I discovered some
kind of weird glitches in the software
uh the biggest glitches were in the
software on my laptop that I use for
downloading a program onto these po
themselves what I discovered is every
single time I tried to add a new image
uh it would do this thing where it would
like kind of push out one of the
previous images to a different number
slot and when it did that it would
replace whichever image originally had
that number slot with the new one so
tend to muck up my programs um I would
recommend that if you're going to make
your own programs that you add all the
images you want to have in your timeline
first and then start dragging them down
to the timeline um because doing it the
other way honestly proved to be very
very frustrating um I will also say that
the program appears to be a little bit
behind the times because as I was
looking through the drop down for the
different po models to kind of see how
the images would look uh on these uh the
48 inoy were not in the list all that
said I get the feeling that the reason
that that program is a little janky with
these is that ignis is kind of moving
towards getting people to use the
smartphone app more often and I can't
say I disagree with that you cannot yet
make a custom program with the
smartphone app the best you could do is
just stick some images you want on there
and have somebody say offstage uh going
through the specific images that you
want as you want them uh which you know
it's a little bit of extra work but um
it actually would probably take less
time to do than than writing a program
and downloading it I think these are
four people who are kind of like getting
a start uh with their professional
careers as performers and need a set of
programmable POI that are an affordable
price but still a professional enough
product that they can show up to a gig
and know that they're going to be able
to still shine um and I think these po
do a pretty good job of that my biggest
qual with these is I wish they came with
an instruction manual there were so many
things that I kind of discovered
accidentally as I was playing around
with them that I wish that I had known
right from the get-go um I think having
instruction like even things like you
know being able to unscrew the base and
attach it to those flat plates so you
can stand them up straight no idea what
that was for for the longest time and
just you know having a little
instruction manual with them would have
been really helpful in that regard but
yeah overall do I like the feeling of
these heck yeah I like the feeling of
these These are now in regular rotation
for me um so I got to say uh good job
with these ignis uh I would love to see
an instruction manual and also too has
to be said it's
2025 have ball handles as an option on
your poy uh but other than that yeah uh
I I like these good job here and uh
thanks for sending me a pair to review
the pixel n48 are available now over at
ignis pixel.com for
$539 a pair I believe ignis has a
distributor here in the United States so
uh you don't have to worry so much about
the import times uh I will also say that
I have a promo code through ignis if you
use the uh code direct Factor at
checkout that'll get you a discount on
your order and it helps out the channel
so everybody wins go check that out at
ignis pixel.com do you own a set of the
pixel in G's what has your experience
been with them please leave me a comment
and let me know did you get anything out
of this video please leave a like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel
grow this video and all the videos on my
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my Flo patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
you rock and if you are not currently a
patreon supporter but you'd like to
become one that's easily solved you can
head on over to my patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor poo and sign up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out more reviews of
programmable LED po I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of those
videos up on screen as well as down in
the description thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace